not everyone's losing out in the big US
government shutdown there is no one to
collect the $30 entry fee at Joshua Tree
National Park it means free access for
visitors to one of America's natural
wonders they have to fend for themselves
once they're in though and the essential
facilities with no one to look after
them are closed across the country
national parks are the most striking
example of the cost of the political
gridlock in Washington government
employees regarded as non-essential told
to stay at home the shutdown has an
impact on things like search-and-rescue
teams and Park Rangers to enforce the
rules here there have been reports of
people letting dogs run wild people
driving off-road and even chopping down
some of the trees that give this park
its name some say it's been like a
return to the days of the old Wild West
out here there was disappointment for
this family hoping to pick up Park
souvenirs for the children
but a price worth paying says dad it's
disappointing but we also have a lot of
problems that need to be fixed and
apparently this is the only way we can
do it do you understand why why it was
necessary I do you know I think we got
you know representatives and Senators
and president that everybody needs to
put their own personal differences aside
and work for whose cinema and that's the
American people there was some
government jobs that are regarded as
essential and the shutdown means
thousands working for the likes of the
Federal Aviation Administration are
doing so without pay says Ari Valenti is
one of them he and his colleagues he
says are anxious currently the morale is
really low because they're worried
worried about when they're gonna get
paid in addition to doing their duties
they're worried about when how they're
gonna pay their next bills how they're
gonna feed their family what what will
what will happen if what's gonna happen
with their health insurance back in
Joshua Tree this is peak tourist season
volunteers are helping but the parks
estimated to be losing up to half a
million dollars a day for so many this
shutdown comes at a high cost Gregg
Milam Sky News California